guys tell me a little bit about putting
these costumes together Poliquin well I
only finished my Thursday it was a bit
of kooky putting into it but finally got
it done with some help from my friends
it took me through what you got on today
and I have got some lovely books which
were the hardest part of the whole
costume sticking all the leather and
stuff on it and then the courses that
was quite difficult the easiest thing
were the leggings and the gloves they
were the easiest bit so yeah and you go
to bat here as well oh they're so view
if you hit anyone yet I have five hit
the Gotham City Police I picked them
quite a few times I've hit him a couple
of times it's not a few times actually
yes too many Timoney how does it feels
we hit my Harlequin well it depends you
what we're being hit and most the time
sometimes the pain in the ass quite
literally literally indeed tell me about
this joker Anthony you got here well
breaking character for a moment um yeah
it was it kind of only got finished
today basically we bought like the
gloves and the we died the shirt and
gots a proper suit together but we dyed
it and it was meant to be put this kind
of purple but it came out a nice lie
look so we bought women's jeans and I
was originally going to go without a
jacket then I put my coat on because it
was cold and it kind of worked so we
went for it and the best thing the thing
I love the most is the the shoes
why are they from oh they're from what
were the call was a call it was just a
joke offensive jokes fancy dress on the
internet yeah actually it was I think we
got a quite treatment it was like five
pound down from 50 so was quite having
her and living the hair as well how's
that feel um very very sticky more than
anything else we get and the makeup to
how did you find putting that on I
started trying to do it myself wasn't so
successful she kind of did the rest for
me so it worked out a bit better yeah
who do you think's been the best joke
out of them all because it's been a few
over the years haven't there that's a
very tough question I think I loved
heath ledger's joker I thought it was
great and it was really perfect for the
Christopher Nolan films however best
Joker hands down is gotta be Mark Hamill
gobby Mark Hamill why is he so good
today he got the perfect balance of
hilarious and batshit crazy just right
it was great it was a you know you were
terrified of him and you were laughing
your ass off a time at the same time it
was brilliant at Harlequin she's had
lots of looks over the years I said she
what have you gone for in particular
today I went for the Arkham City game
look cuz I just thought it was a little
bit different from the usual thing and I
thought
cooler and used to prefer the bats over
the mallet do you yeah i think the but
it was mainly because it was easier to
do i found it quite hard finding a big
enough mallet
you